hi there I'm an oppressor Robinson for
gamespot here in the WB booth at e3 2014
my new friend Dax how you doing dad I'm
doing good what do you do that I'm a
producer of Rocksteady Studios North
London it's an easy job no it's not it's
really difficult North London so you
come a long way to be here yeah but I
spent a lot of time in LA working with
Warner Brothers I'm really used to that
flight and I love this city it's great
well we were talking today about batman
arkham knight can you tell us what the
big buzz about Arkham Knight is here at
e3 the big reveal that we've just made
at e3 has been the reveal of battle mode
so the Batmobile was a huge feature
we've been working on for like four
years it's a bit like the epicenter of
the gameplay experience about man Arkham
Knight but the big news is that the
Batmobile is capable of transformation
between pursuit mode and battle mode and
battle mode is really where Batman
really kicks ass with this in sort of
military grade hardware and weapon we
reppin weaponry against the forces that
the Arkham Knight has brought into
Gotham City I I think I saw there's some
really interesting movement that that
battle mode can do can you tell us about
that yeah I mean battle night is a
completely different gameplay mode from
pursuit mode biscuit visiplate is about
driving fast when you transform into
battle mode at the touch of a button you
can then navigate the Batmobile in a
completely different ways so it can
strafe it can dodge left and right but
mostly it's about unleashing the
weaponry that it has on board to really
fight back against Arkham Knights forces
very cool so we kind of got this battle
tank mode we've got this pursuit racing
type mode and then of course with Batman
we're always talking about the actual
fighting sequences right so what can we
expect there the free flow combat has
always been something that we put a load
of energy into because it just that's
the thing that makes you feel like
Batman right being surrounded by 20 or
30 thugs but being in control of that
situation the funny thing is we then
extended that whole philosophy into the
battle mode system so when you're
fighting in the Batmobile in battle mode
you'll be surrounded by 10 20 different
tanks or different kind of military
enemies but you're still in control of
the situation there's a load of
different gameplay systems we've built
in there so that gamers will feel like
that the battle mode experience is just
an extension of the free folk combat
system that everyone so it's so familiar
with so we're going to see a lot of the
things that we love most about Batman
but
kind of taking a leap forward in terms
of our options into vehicular combat
like anything's possible and then at any
time you can eject out of the Batmobile
gained insane height glide across the
skyline of Gotham City that sense of
freedom that you get when the entirety
of Gotham City is yours and you can just
go wherever you want like it feels
awesome but it feels so genuinely Batman
like now we're working with you know
newer and more exciting technology in
games right now how has that impacted
the development of batman arkham knight
having the horsepower of next-gen was
something that we really wanted to use
to challenge ourselves to create
something new at the same time we knew
that gamers have been asking us to put
the Batmobile in there ever since Arkham
Asylum but to do justice to the
Batmobile you really need to be able to
make sure you can drive it insane speed
you can deliver kind of epic destruction
as you're driving through the city we
just couldn't do that without the power
of next-gen so the timing really worked
well for us that was the thing that we
decided we're going to put all of our
energy into making sure the next-gen
experience of Batman at Rocksteady is
really focused around bringing the
Batmobile to life it sounds like it's
going to be very immersive kind of you
know walking around really as the Batman
have somebody who hasn't gotten to play
it yet can you tell me about that
experience how it feels to really walk
around in this game it's all about the
city that's the thing I mean being
Batman is kind of a fantasy that's the
promise of the game but being Batman in
Gotham City means we have to create a
game world which didn't just feel like a
city it's gonna feel like Gotham City
and that means the weather's got to be
right it's always got to be nighttime
the the sensor kind of commercial
reality kind of neon lights and signage
all of that lives within the kind of
fiction of Gotham City that people know
so well from movies and comics that's
something bring that to life in a game
world it's just a huge job and it's got
to be right because the atmosphere of
Gotham City is unlike any other city and
if it's a bit off people totally get it
they expect the atmosphere to be bang on
so our art teamed and our director Dave
he go he's genuine he spent the last
four years just making sure that is
right the rain alone has has taken so
much time at rock steady but I think the
rain is actually my favorite bit of the
entire game it's so cool really well I
love the rain I'm really looking forward
to experiencing that environment for
myself really appreciate your time thank
you so much dad my pleasure thanks Anna
you